how are you feeling about aging I'm not
doing well with it nobody does well with
it no how's your health do you feel
robust from that end of it I feel
perfectly fine I mean I feel no
different I could jump on stage now and
do do the show you know but um it's it's
a process right you don't you never grow
up no you know I mean it's the fact you
know you get to a certain St you're
growing down you know I'm waiting for
the
diapers was rehab harder or smoke which
one well right quit and smoking actually
I found the quitting smoking fairly easy
really yeah it was just something that
said inside that said now you you got it
and you know you got that inner force
that
says okay you know I mean this is no
[__] foot in uh you gotta and uh
comparatively easy far easier than
boot right really yeah